[Musica]
vorrei cominciare raccontandovi una
storia è una storia che potrebbe
risalire agli albori
dell'umanità una storia che ha per
protagonista una ruota Ma non voglio
portarvi in epoca preistorica è una
ruota che può però condizionare le
nostre scelte questa storia riguarda la
ruota del carrello della spesa Vi è mai
capitato di guidare il carrello
attraverso le corsie e di notare una
ruota
dinoccolata in qualche modo il carrello
è costretto a rallentare E allora
Secondo i teorici di questa storia forse
sarebbe meglio chiamarla una leggenda
metropolitana anche che la ruota del
carrello della spesa avrebbe a che fare
con il marketing servirebbe in vero a
rallentare il nostro percorso di
consumatori all'interno delle corsie in
questo modo ci guardiamo intorno e forse
compreremo di più ma non è tutto se
questa storia può sembrare Incredibile
In effetti lo è qualcun altro sostiene
che persino il pavimento che incontriamo
all'interno del supermercato abbia a che
fare con le nostre scelte perché
percorrendo questa pavimentazione fatta
di piccole mattonelle il rumore
fastidioso che è generato dalle ruote
del carrello della spesa Ci indurrebbe
ancora una volta a rallentare il nostro
percorso trat tenendoci quindi di più
per più tempo all'interno del punto
vendita allo scopo ancora una volta di
farci comprare di più ora se queste sono
delle leggende dalle quali prendo anche
un po' le distanze quello che è
certamente vero è che all'interno del
supermercato siamo oggetto di tante
tecniche di marketing si parla di Self
marketing il marketing dello Scaffale
una necessaria premessa non sto
demonizzando il supermercato Anzi è un
luogo che io adoro una specie di
laboratorio del marketing dove vediamo
messe in atto tutte queste tecniche a
volte manipolatorie e aggiungo anche che
vi sto parlando del supermercato ma
potrei parlarvi di ogni punto vendita
della farmacia del negozio di
abbigliamento dell'autosalone persino di
un ferramenta ed allora avviciniamoci al
supermercato tornando Più seriamente sul
carrello della spesa vi sarete accorti
che generalmente i carrelli moderni sono
sovradimensionati rispetto alle nostre
esigenze Beh il marketing del
supermercato Comincia proprio qui quel
carrello enorme smisurato ha una
funzione serve a darci questo senso di
vuoto anche se abbiamo fatto gli
acquisti che avevamo annotato sulla
nostra lista della spesa beh quel
carrello sembra guardarci e con tutto
quel vuoto ricordarci che non abbiamo
comprato abbastanza questo se ci pensate
ha a che fare con la mappa del nostro
supermercato è molto difficile che voi
troviate all'inizio del percorso dei
prodotti ingombranti le casse dell'acqua
o anche le grandi confe i di carta
igienica o i rotoloni difficilmente sono
all'inizio del nostro percorso
all'interno del supermercato perché se
andassimo a riempire subito il carrello
Ecco che svanirebbe quell'effetto di
vuoto al supermercato Ci accoglie il
reparto della frutta e della verdura lo
sapete tutti e perché accade perché
questi colori questi odori ci danno un
senso di piacevolezza ci sembra quasi di
trovarci all'interno di un mercato
contadino anche se magari stiamo
entrando in un supermercato di
dimensioni enormi il buon umore gli
ormoni del buon umore ci spingono a
comprare di più e quindi frutta e
verdura all'inizio del percorso servono
a farci entrare nel supermercato con la
giusta idea di acquisto ma c'è una
ragione più sottile che forse non Tutti
conoscono perché frutta e verdura sono
all'inizio del nostro percorso si tratta
di acquist complicati faticosi più
faticosi che farete all'interno del
supermercato non so se ci avete pensato
ma indossare i guanti di plastica
scegliere la frutta la verdura metterla
sulla bilancia estrarre il lo scontrino
che si appiccica sui sui guanti Insomma
diventa estremamente complicato il
supermercato vuole avere dei consumatori
freschi e riposati in quel momento del
percorso Se ci pensate bene se questo
reparto fosse alla fine Beh
probabilmente il consumatore stanco
dedicherebbe molta meno attenzione a
questi acquisti che pure il supermercato
vuole stimolare non solo perché soggetti
ad una frequente rotazione ma anche
perché il suo margine è più ampio e per
i più pigri di solito proprio vicino al
reparto della frutta e della verdura
troviamo quella confezionata si chiama
quarta gamma l'insalata in busta per Non
deludere
nessuno talvolta all'inizio del nostro
percorso viene stimolato anche il nostro
olfatto e possiamo trovare come in
questo caso il reparto del pane ancora
una volta quell'odore quella fragranza
serve a stimolare gli ormoni che poi ci
faranno propendere per degli acquisti
che forse non avevamo
preventivato tutto al supermercato ha
una funzione abbiamo detto dei colori
dei profumi ma anche degli delle
circostanze che forse non cadono sotto i
nostri occhi come la musica e
l'illuminazione studi scientifici ci
dicono che con la giusta musica nelle
orecchie un consumatore può comprare
fino al
10% di più pensate quanto siano
manipolabili le nostre scelte la musica
può persino accelerare o rallentare il
nostro passo e quindi se lo notate
succederà che nei momenti di Massimo
affollamento del supermercato La musica
è veloce e ritmata Perché il
supermercato vuole che noi acceleriamo
le operazioni per evitare di creare
troppo affollamento viceversa nei
momenti in cui al supermercato ci sono
meno persone la musica sarà più lenta
per rallentare il nostro passo e poi la
luce e non mi riferisco
all'illuminazione delle corsie
ovviamente ma alla luce che illumina
singoli prodotti ancora una volta studi
scientifici spiegano che il nostro
cervello è attirato dai colori vivi e
quindi la carne è illuminata da una luce
che ne Attiva la colorazione rossa ma
anche il pesce per evidenzi le branchie
del pesce per l'appunto e farcelo
sembrare ancora più
fresco il grande trucco del supermercato
però consiste nel volerci trattenere
all'interno il più a lungo possibile Un
po' lo abbiamo detto ed è una tecnica
che il supermercato condivide con il
casinò Alla fine più tempo passiamo al
tavolo da gioco e più soldi getteremo
così come più tempo passiamo davanti
allo scaffale e più acquisti faremo Cosa
hanno in comune un supermercato e un cas
No non so se l'avete notato ma né
all'interno del supermercato né
all'interno del casinò troveremo delle o
degli orologi perché tanto gli uni che
gli altri servono a ricordarci il
contatto con la realtà e invece il
casinò e anche il supermercato Vogliono
farci vivere in una specie di trans di
separazione rispetto a quel che accade
all'esterno ma un'altra tecnica che il
supermercato utilizza per farci restare
il più a lungo possibile all'interno del
punto vendita è quella di spostare
talvolta persino nascondere i prodotti
Sarà capitato anche a voi di andare a
cercare la pasta dove ricordavate di
averla trovata la settimana scorsa e di
non trovarla più lì semplicemente perché
il supermercato ha deciso di collocarla
altrove qualcosa del genere succede
addirittura con i prodotti essenziali
quelli che sono all'inizio della lista
della spesa Beh quelli davvero il
supermercato Prova a nasconderli il sale
lo zuccchero la farina lievito dovete
per forza chiedere dove sono e questo
perché il supermercato vuole farvi
navigare non soltanto le zone calde
quelle più frequentate ma anche le zone
fredde e proprio G andrà a collocare
questi prodotti senza i quali non potete
tornare a casa il supermercato ci fa
girare e questi giri all'interno del
punto vendita sono generalmente in senso
antiorario lo vediamo bene nei punti
vendita che troviamo durante la sosta in
autostrada quelle serpentine che ci
conduc conducono fino alla cassa giriamo
verso sinistra e questo non soltanto
perché l'umanità per la maggior parte
destrorsa quindi tendiamo più facilmente
a girarci verso il nostro lato forte ma
per una manipolazione ancora più sottile
il nostro cervello è abituato a leggere
Da sinistra verso destra Facendoci
girare all'incontrario i nostri sensi
sono un po' disorientati e quindi più
attivi e ancora una volta ci guarderemo
intorno con Maggiore attenzione e poi
cosa accade accade che le confezioni dei
prodotti devono attirare la nostra
attenzione Non so se ci avete mai
pensato ma la grande innovazione del
supermercato non è soltanto un punto
vendita più grande ma è il concetto di
un enorme self service Noi prendiamo i
prodotti da soli al supermercato e
quindi quel prodotto ci deve in qualche
modo chiamare dallo scaffale attirare la
nostra attenzione lo vediamo soprattutto
con le merendine con queste foto
bellissime super photoshoppate poi basta
aprire per scoprire un po' di delusione
le immagini hanno un'importanza
straordinaria quelle riprodotte sui
prodotti servono proprio a spingerci a
metterli all'interno del carrello alcune
sono un po' scostumate e mi riferisco a
quelle che guardano al consumatore più
giovane in particolare sulle scatole dei
cereali non so se l'avete notato ci sono
dei personaggi dei cartoni animati
Questa è una cosa scorretta non si può
strizzare l'occhio a un consumatore che
non è proprio in grado di
autodeterminarsi tanto che le grandi
multi nazionali che producono questo
genere di prodotti ma anche molti altri
che giocano con i cartoni animati con i
personaggi più amati dai più piccoli
stanno cercando di autoregolamentarsi
proprio per evitare queste pratiche
scorrette e poi ci sono le etichette gli
sticker sui prodotti ve ne faccio vedere
qualcuna nuova ricetta Questo è un
grande classico alzi la mano Chi ha
assaggiato un prodotto con su scritto
nuova ricetta e l' ha trovato più buono
del precedente naturalmente è sempre un
peggioramento nuova ricetta vuol dire
che hanno tolto degli ingredienti di
valore li hanno sostituiti con
ingredienti un po' più scarsi e poi c'è
il marketing del senza il free from
marketing si chiama proprio così ormai
il consumatore è convinto che un
prodotto senza qualcosa sia migliore
senza zucchero senza grassi senza
lattosio senza colesterolo c'è quella
particella di sodio sperduta che sembra
essere all'interno della bottiglia
dell'acqua minerale un valore ma non è
detto che sia così un prodotto potrebbe
anche piacerci perché è più ricco o
magari far più bene alla nostra salute
perché più ricco e poi questa questa è
un grande classico chi mi segue sui
social sa che io impazzisco di fronte ai
formati che non esistono più più 10% di
prodotto ma rispetto a cosa non c'è più
il mezzo kg di pasta o il mezzo litro di
acqua tutti i formati sono ormai
diventati diversi hanno li hanno sempre
un po'
sgrammaticati spesso credono a queste
etichette e poi c'è la grande magia del
posizionamento sugli scaffali Voi sapete
che i prodotti più preziosi il
supermercato li colloca all'altezza dei
nostri occhi Anzi per la verità sono i
produttori che pagano per mettere i
prodotti nei luoghi dove il consumatore
li vedrà più facilmente il luogo ideale
proprio davanti ai nostri occhi a
portata delle nostre mani quindi un
piccolo consiglio per chi domani andrà a
fare la spesa Se volete comprare
prodotti che costano meno è probabile
che li troverete più in alto o più in
basso rispetto a quelli che sono proprio
davanti ai vostri occhi altra tecnica
del marketing del supermercato è il
Cross selling Cosa vuol dire vuol dire
cercare di vendere due prodotti insieme
e quindi cosa fa il supermercato colloca
vicini vicini di scaffale prodotti i cui
consumi sono generalmente abbinati
Questo è un grande classico vedete sullo
sfondo le confezioni di pasta e in primo
piano le salse chiaramente salse e pasta
vengono consumati insieme può essere
utile se abbiamo di dimenticato di
scrivere uno di questi prodotti sulla
lista della spesa altre volte ci
suggeriscono forse dei consumi non
proprio necessari ancora le patatine
vicino alle bibite e quando proprio non
è possibile far questo c'è un Cross
selling che il supermercato improvvisa
anche in modo un po' rudimentale qui
troviamo i gli apribottiglie davanti
alle bottiglie di birra e poi c'è l'ap
Selling cioè venderci qualcos'altro o
più quantità dello stesso prodotto cosa
che gen finalmente accade al banco della
gastronomia quando l'ha detto dopo aver
affettato il prosciutto stranamente ci
chiede se può lasciare quei 50 o quegli
80 g in più rispetto alla nostra
richiesta anche questa è un
condizionamento Delle nostre scelte ogni
reparto al supermercato ha la sua storia
Questa è una delle più interessanti il
reparto dei vini vedete in questa foto
il reparto dei vini sembra avere un
contesto diverso il supermercato
organizza questo luogo con particolare
attenzione in qualche caso persino
cambiando la pavimentazione attaccando
un parquet posticcio su quelle
mattonelle di cui vi parlavo prima
perché accade perché per il vino il
consumatore è condizionato dal prezzo
dall'idea del valore di quel prodotto
chi non è un esperto si lascia
convincere dal valore reale o percepito
del prodotto ed è chiaro che
trasformandosi almeno in quell'angolo in
un'enoteca il supermercato ci vorrà
comprare vini non da supermercato MA da
inoteca e quindi più costosi altra
tecnica che racconto spesso sui social è
quella dei prodotti alla rinfusa Vi è
mai capitato di incontrare delle grandi
ceste proprio sul vostro percorso o dei
bancali in mezzo alla corsia con dei
prodotti che sembrano essere messi lì
per caso ancora una volta questo
condiziona le nostre scelte il nostro
cervello associa all'idea di confusione
quella di basso costo un prodotto messo
in una cesta allar infusa sembra un
prodotto che il supermercato voglia eh
vendere rapidamente Magari sono delle
rimanenze magari si tratterà di qualcosa
che ci costerà di meno ma non è così
Andate a verificare se quella pasta o le
scatolette di tonno che sembrano essere
state appoggiate distrattamente in una
cesta hanno davvero un prezzo
conveniente oppure no il prodotto più
prezioso per il supermercato Viene
collocato generalmente alla fine della
cors alla fine della corsia c'è il luogo
che i produttori sono disposti a pagare
più caro è un luogo dove il consumatore
esita per un attimo deve decidere se
andare a destra a sinistra e in quella
frazione di secondo si guarderà intorno
con più attenzione rispetto al fluire
normale della corsia spesso ci sono
degli espositori che come vedete
attirano nostra attenzione perché sono
diversi sono colorati sono tematizzati
questo luogo ha un nome non c'entra
l'imbarcazione Veneziana Ma si chiama
testata di gondola perché un po' ricorda
la forma della prua della della gondola
veneziana e in questo luogo troviamo
prodotti che il supermercato vuole
valorizzare magari una nuova linea di
biscotti appena lanciata oppure prodotti
inattesi per un supermercato come
possono essere dei giochi per i bambini
o vedete sempre in questa foto dei
mestoli per la per la
cucina parliamo di prezzi anche i prezzi
naturalmente alterano le nostre scelte
ci sono molti modi di raccontare il
prezzo Sì avete capito bene quello
stesso prezzo può essere raccontato in
modi diversi si chiamano Charming prices
cioè prezzi attraenti o prezzi soglia
sono quelli che finiscono con nove ma il
gioco che fa il nostro cervello non ha a
che fare con l'arrotondamento tutti noi
sappiamo che questi sono €10 la nostra
testa è invece influenzata da quello che
è chiamato left Digit Effect effetto
della cifra di sinistra il nostro
cervello qui vede soltanto il nove vede
solo la decina anche se in realtà come
vi dicevo sono quasi €10 anzi sono €10
un'altra tecnica per depotenziare il
prezzo ai nostri occhi è quella di far
sparire semplicemente l'indicazione
della valuta togliere la scritta euro ci
fa pensare nel nostro inconscio di
pagare di meno e ancora si può giocare
con la grafica si può ridurre i
centesimi e farli davvero sparire ai
nostri occhi tecniche che sono molto
efficaci abbiamo parlato di prezzi vuol
dire che ci stiamo avvicinando alla
cassa ma il nostro viaggio non è finito
perché finalmente troveremo quelle casse
dell'acqua che il supermercato non ha
voluto mettere all'inizio perché sennò
avrebbero occupato troppo spazio nel
carrello Ma questa è una cosa
irrazionale perché ora dovremmo mettere
le casse dell'acqua sopra i prodotti che
abbiamo già messo nel carrello magari
quella frutta e quella verdura che
rischieranno di essere danneggiati ma al
supermercato poca importa quel che conta
è averci spinto a consumi inattesi E a
proposito di consumi inattesi via via
che ci avviciniamo alle casse del
supermercato compaiono fanno Capolino
dagli scaffali i dolci le caramelle non
sono nella nostra lista della spesa
nessuno credo di voi andrà al
supermercato scrivendo Ricordati di
comprare una tavoletta di cioccolato
nella sua lista della spesa ma
trovandoli alla fine del percorso quando
quel consumatore ha già comprato at la
verdura si è fatto convincere da molti
altri acquisti Beh arrivato a questo
punto il consumatore nella sua testa
pensa di avere diritto ad una ricompensa
ed è per questo che si tratterrà in
questo reparto e probabilmente comprerà
dei dolci e di dolci Son piene le Avan
casse altro luogo molto prezioso del
supermercato dove il marketing gioca con
la noia dell'attesa del nostro turno con
i dolcetti messi purtroppo proprio
all'altezza dei bambini che tir anno la
giacca al papà OA mamma per comprarli e
infine uno sguardo al supermercato del
futuro Il supermercato del futuro
rispetto a quello di oggi giocherà
ancora di più con i dati il supermercato
attuale sa quello che noi portiamo alla
casassa Ognuno di noi ha uno scontrino
ha acquistato dei prodotti Il
supermercato del futuro così come le
grandi piattaforme dell'e-commerce
moderno sapranno anche i prodotti che
abbiamo abbandonato nel carrello tutti
noi abbiamo dei prodotti abbandonati nel
carrello della grande piattaforma di
e-commerce e quelle sono delle
informazioni importanti perché dicono
Molto di noi sui nostri comportamenti su
quello che forse non abbiamo ancora
deciso di comprare Beh il supermercato
del futuro avrà anche questa
opportunità vorrei concludere citando
Anzi parafrasando un caro amico che si
occupa di intelligenza del linguaggio il
messaggio è questo se saprete prendervi
cura delle vostre scelte Beh allora le
vostre scelte si prenderanno cura di voi
e sarete saremo finalmente dei super
consumatori
Grazie